you probably watch listen to or at the
very least heard about Joe Rogan's
interview with tech giant Elan musk from
last week Joe and Alan had a
wide-ranging discussion for two and a
half hours about evolution technology
market simulation theory and much more
immediately after though the headlines
were all about the blunt that they
smoked in the last 20 minutes along with
the very me mobile image of Alan with
smoke surrounding his head
shortly after Alan's Rogen interview
aired to topic Tesla executives resigned
and Tesla's stock dropped significantly
the usual suspects wrote think pieces
questioning whether musk was mentally
stable or fit to be an executive at the
very company he created I think the
majority of people found the whole
ordeal to be kind of funny and quirky
you know like a surprising moment that
makes life kind of interesting but
apparently these days if you do anything
that doesn't conform to groupthink
there's a media click machine that'll
see blood and is waiting to strike now
first off weed is totally completely
100% legal here in California I'm
guessing that you person watching this
right now have probably tried it once or
twice yourself maybe even inhaled but
perhaps more importantly than legal
issue or whether marijuana has health
benefits impairs your judgment or all of
the above lies a more important question
Elan musk may be a little nutty but is
unquestionably one of the most important
visionaries we have today beyond Tesla
his electric car company which has
revolutionized the automobile industry
he's also the founder and CEO of SpaceX
which is sending rockets beyond Earth's
orbit and will most likely make life on
Mars a reality within our lifetime if
that's not enough his ironically named
boring company is building tunnels under
Los Angeles in an attempt to relieve
LA's infamously insane traffic in short
Elan isn't just changing the world for
the better he's creating the reality of
a future that most people can only dream
of
while the Elan marihuana memes were
great they overshadow the conversation
with one of the
few modern visionaries we have left as
Tesla employees stepped down or traders
worried about Musk's behavior perhaps
it's just this adventurous attitude
which allows musk to solve problems
while most people just complain think
the automobile industry is moving on
electric cars to slowly create tesla
think NASA isn't exploring space fast
enough start SpaceX while we all talk a
few people actually do and for those who
do maybe being different isn't a flaw in
the system it's part of the design since
when do we live in a time when our
geniuses can't have idiosyncratic quirks
or act out in ways that make them stand
apart from the rest of us our inventors
need the room to be different because
that different way of thinking is where
they find the spark that ignites their
genius with all this in mind let's shift
to the very company which put a line on
the map he co-created PayPal alongside
another misunderstood tech giant Peter
teal teal the guy on the left in this
picture is an entrepreneur venture
capitalist philanthropist author and my
guests on the Rubin report this week
perhaps even more than musk teal seems
to be misunderstood by the media which
seems more interested in him as a
caricature than as a person over the
last two years I've become friends with
Peter through his friend and my friend
and confidant Eric Weinstein I know
Peter to be an open decent thoughtful
curious person someone who privately is
all of the things that the media says he
is not and that's the person I hope to
introduce you to today beyond founding
PayPal teal was also the first outside
investor in facebook who turned 500
thousand dollars into considerably more
than that he also funded Hulk Hogan's
lawsuit which ultimately toppled Gawker
a move many think was an attack against
the media but I believe to be a seminal
moment in defense of the Fourth
Amendment which defended our right to
privacy peter has become the ultimate
contrarian in the tech world of Silicon
Valley which has become stagnant and
dull when's the last time you were
really excited about a new app for your
phone remember when there was a new app
every day that you just had to have
those days seem to be long gone
and Peter sees a reason for it he has
long talked about the dangers of
groupthink and faux diversity two of the
idea destroying forces which have taken
over the tech world
that's exactly why his recent move from
Silicon Valley to Los Angeles has
happened
yeah that's right LA is suddenly
becoming a home of free thought thanks
to the creatively crushing progressive
or cathode oxy that has taken over
Silicon Valley we live in strange times
indeed
Peter was also the person with the
highest profile in the tech world to
support Donald Trump for president and
even spoke at the Republican National
Convention when he told a roomful of
Republicans that he was proud to be gay
he received a thunderous round of
applause and I remember thinking how
that moment was a powerful shift in the
Democratic lock on gay Americans and the
beginning of a new perhaps more tolerant
Republican Party til had no idea if he
was gonna get booed or cheered at that
moment but I believe that the new
libertarian view the Republican Party
has taken on marriage equality is in
large part because Peter dared to stand
up for what he believed in even if it
was against conservative orthodoxy with
so much in flux in the world right now
people like Alan and Peter have more of
a chance to shape the future than ever
before as old institutions continue to
crumble we need new visionaries to build
us the institutions of the future if
they're quirky or misunderstood then
they're probably exactly the people we
need to get the job done
you
[Music]